[Music]
the border crisis is now facing a
housing crisis for the thousands of
migrants trying to get into the u.s
and the hundreds of law enforcement
workers who have nowhere to put them
correspondent bill malugen reports
tonight from la jolla texas
the fox flight team over mcallen texas
early wednesday morning where we've
learned overnight
the city began constructing these
emergency shelters meant to house
illegal immigrants
released from border patrol custody by
afternoon migrants had already started
arriving
the city says they have to build this
compound to help house an
overwhelming amount of migrants left
stranded in mcallen
after release by the federal government
the city writing in a statement
they intend to quote demand relief from
the federal government for the alarming
number of immigrants that are being
released into the city of mcallen
and that as these immigrants are
released the federal government does not
test them for kovit 19.
back on monday we were in downtown
mcallen as we watched border patrol drop
off busloads of migrants every 30
minutes
releasing them from their custody to a
catholic charity
that no longer has the capacity to take
in so many people
the city of mcallen says the federal
government has released over
7 thousand coveted positive migrants
into their city
since february including more than 1500
in just the last week alone the biden
administration is now reportedly
planning to begin offering covid 19
vaccines
to illegal immigrants in federal custody
now with these emergency shelters going
up to try to help contain the crisis
locals we talked to aren't happy it was
done overnight
with no warning we're inundated we know
that we're inundated and truthfully i
believe there's probably not enough
planes or buses to get all these people
out of
here but again there probably could have
been a better
location than sticking it right smack in
the middle of mcallen it's
just really scary because just right
across the street from
this holding facility you see homes
where people live
and shannon we got some late breaking
news like to report to you right now
just got a few texts from a contact with
texas dps apparently there was just a
horrible vehicle crash in brooks county
south of the
falfurious border patrol station about
an hour south of where we are right now
what we're told
is there was a van driving 24 people in
it
all of them suspected to be illegal
immigrants that driver veered off the
road
crashed into a utility pole there's 11
confirmed dead people right now
including the driver 13 hurt they're
still investigating this they're in the
process of identifying the dead
and notifying the mexican consulate but
a horrible horrible crash i'm told there
was not a pursuit here these were just
migrants
being transported unclear if it was a
human smuggler but 11
dead right now horribly tragic incident
we'll send it back to you
all right bill we will track that story
thank you